[Music]
this is you're about to enter the
enemy's
the Animus is a machine that allows
somebody to revisit the lives of their
ancestors searching for time frame
insert aperture as memory much lot the
scientists they're linked by their DNA
so all of their memories are the side of
descent
welcome to the Spanish Inquisition it is
a genetic time trouble when I saw it it
felt real it was the subjects enter the
enemies and they take the place of one
of their ancestors through the
projection of your genetic memories it
allows us to observe in you to relive
the night of your ancestors
I'm beginning to like this
it's a very cool experience it's just a
fantastic concept
your pass
[Music]
you hear to say to myself I understand
it's your birthday
yeah the party's just getting started
his name is Kellerman
we've traced his bloodline back 500
years to the Assassin's Creed cow as
anyone in the world knows or cares you
no longer exist what is this place
this is your second chance
[Music]
your past you're about to enter the
Animus what you see here and feel are
the memories of your ancestor who's been
dead for 500 years
wait a minute welcome to the Spanish
Inquisition
what I saw it there and family
it was
you're watching you waiting to see who
you are
I believe you are destined for great
things that's fine now
we work in the dark just turn up the
light
we are assassins
I'm beginning to like this
in terms of the fighting poverty are
these weapon of choice with the blades
on the wrists
very important